écouter aujourd'hui vidéo très spéciale
pour fêter les 10 ans de game of thrones
et quoi de mieux qu'un petit peu de
spéculation de mystère de fantasmes
autour de la série pour lui rendre
honneur
malgré une saison finale qui a fortement
divisé les téléspectateurs eh bien il
existe encore de grosses zones d'ombré
qui planent encore sur l'histoire s'est
néanmoins là la force de cette saison 8
nous proposer une fin ouverte pour
beaucoup de personnages principaux afin
que nos spectateurs puissions imaginer
ce qui arriverait ensuite est évidemment
bas c'est ce que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui la trinité se réunit donc
aujourd'hui pour vous proposer une
trilogie de vidéos reliées entre elles
le destin de john snow de mon côté la
résurrection de daenerys chez hijos f et
ça c'est beau et enfin bran stark le
manipulateur chez maistre thibault
huissier de justice vous constatez
maistre je constate c'est la vérité
constaté m comme moi je ne vois but
pêche bref il est grand temps
d'approfondir la grande histoire de game
of thrones avec cette vidéo post saison
8 donc attention spoil vous êtes averti
qu est devenu john snow à la fin de la
série
[Musique]
c'est une question tout à fait légitime
mais qui vous allez voir cache bien des
secrets originellement un descendant de
l'union d'un targaryen et d'une stark de
par ses valeurs morales et son honneur
ou encore sa condition d'élus du peuple
john snow et le roi que nous attendions
tous la seconde option est la véritable
derrière une daenerys assoiffés de
pouvoir et qui dans une logique de
succession devrait passer normalement
après john malheureusement étant le seul
à véritablement pouvoir stopper daenerys
dans son noble nubile à sion c'est
autour d'une scène très shakespearienne
que john tuera l'amour de sa vie
le devoir prenant le pas sur l'amour
emprisonné par les immaculés en colère
notamment vers gris le destin de john
sera tranchée par le nouveau roi des six
couronnes bran le briser john sera amené
à la garde de nuit pour vivre en exil
une excuse en quelque sorte puisqu'il
retrouvera finalement les sauvageons le
peuple libre et ce en ira au delà du mur
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
que va-t-il advenir de john et bien une
certaine beauté se dégage dans
l'amertume de la fin de john snow
car dans une spéculation logique de par
le passé du personnage ses actions
l'unification qu'il a créé avec le
peuple libre et le reste de westeros
il est très simple de se dire que john
deviendrait le nouveau roi des
sauvageons comme l'était originellement
monstre haider une idée qui fait que
john est finalement devenu un roi mais
pas celui que nous attendions
spécialement néanmoins et si le récit ne
s'arrêtait pas qu'à cette simple idée
tout d'abord il faut remémorer certaines
choses concernant john
c'est son unicité dans le récit et si je
décide de parler de lui aujourd'hui
c'est qu'encore beaucoup de choses me
chiffonne par rapport à ce personnage
des éléments qui n'ont toujours pas été
résolu malgré la fin de game of thrones
par exemple sa résurrection
certainement la scène la plus importante
de la saison 6 mélissandre va tenter de
réanimer john snow qui avaient perdu la
vie du à l'embuscade prévu par ses ex
frère de la garde de nuit elle
mélisandre qui a de nombreuses fois
échoué et perdu la foi a réussi à
ramener la vie dans le corps de john
snow
mais nous n'avons jamais véritablement
su pourquoi
évidemment la raison la plus sensée et
que john est celui qui a permis
d'unifier tous le monde face aux
marcheurs blanc mais encore une fois ce
n'est jamais véritablement confirmé est
encore plus troublant john n'était pas
destinée à tuer le roi de la nuit et ne
l'a jamais été par les showrunners john
snow a été un soldat comme les autres
durant la longue nuit et cela s'arrête
là et autres éléments qui dérange
également c'est le cas de berric dont
dario ce célèbre personnage qui a été
tué six fois et réanimer à chaque fois
c'est mélisandre elle même qui dira à
aria lors de l'ultime mort de berric que
ce dernier a été réanimé car il avait
une mission à accomplir et que c'est
maintenant fait
c'est pourquoi il meurt définitivement
dans la symbolique et ce n'est pas la
première oeuvre cinématographique à
traiter ce cas de figure le fait de
ramener quelqu'un à la vie pour qu'ils
accomplissent une mission sous entend
qu'il doit accomplir quelque chose pour
enfin trouver la paix et partir
sereinement ce n'est pas le cas de john
avec son récit qui se termine amèrement
john est toujours en vie à la fin de la
série et si sa mission n'était donc
toujours pas accompli
brandon stark devenu bran le briser le
nouveau roi des six couronnes et celui
qui pourrait nous apporter des réponses
inutile de rappeler à quel point bran
peut être omniscient et prévoir beaucoup
de choses ce dernier nous l'a démontré
pendant la bataille de la longue nuit et
via son ascension au trône devenue la
corneille à trois yeux branne et celui
qui incarne l'histoire de l'humanité et
oriente ses camarades pour faire les
bons choix
par le biais de son élection en tant que
roi de westeros branagh a obtenu les
pleins pouvoirs et ce sont de nouvelles
possibilités qui s'offrent à lui
si nous restons dans l'idée que la
mission de john n'est pas terminé nous
pouvons supposer que bran oriente john à
l'accomplir définitivement vous allez
comprendre le fait que john est tué
daenerys a suscité un très gros débat
parmi les dirigeants de west et rose
certains voulant le voir mort pour
venger la reine déchue
d'autres comme le reste des stark
préférant rester fidèle à john et c'est
bien brad qui tranchera le débat en
choisissant d'exilés john au delà du mur
sauf que ce sort imposé par bran seul et
je rappelle bien qu'il est le seul à
avoir commandité cela est bien c'est un
petit peu une punition incohérente
puisque vers gris qui est le principal
commanditaire de la mort de john s'en va
pour lille de nas avec le reste des
immaculés yara quand elle s'en retourne
aux îles de faire et voilà
en vérité notamment par le biais de la
récente indépendance du nord john
pourrait très bien vivre là-bas
tranquillement sans être considérés sur
les terres des six royaume sans oublier
qu'il est très apprécié par ses
compatriotes du nord et que sa soeur
sand ça et maintenant la reine mêmes
sont tout cela à john pourrait très bien
revenir sans que cela pose de véritables
problèmes puisque tous ceux qui
voulaient le voir mort sont
définitivement partie mais bon bref
alors pourquoi envoyer john au delà du
mur est-ce que cela ne cacherait pas
quelque chose d'autre nous pouvons
d'ailleurs comparé la peine à celle de
tyrion qui bon jeu l'accord n'a pas tué
daenerys mai
il l'a quand même trahi abandonné et
c'est même rebeller contre elle ce
dernier a été fait main du roi pour
racheter ses erreurs
alors que dans le cas de john bail ne
peut pas se racheter il est banni et
c'est tout c'est terminé enfin bref
cette peine est très étrange d'ailleurs
n'oublions pas que bran est actuellement
à la recherche de drogue ont pour on ne
sait quelle raison
drogon qui après le meurtre de daenerys
s'en est allée avec le corps de sa mère
vers volantis à l'est de westeros sur le
continent des sauces et si du coup cette
mission inachevée guidé par bran était
liée aux marcheurs blanc ce qui me fait
aller dans cette direction est en
premier lieu tout le symbolisme apportée
par branne et john snow les deux points
centraux de la théorie john est un
piètre politique il l'a maintes fois
prouvé notamment en présence de daenerys
john est avant tout considéré comme le
gardien des hommes face à la mort donc
tout un symbole de magie il est l'ennemi
des marcheurs blanc celui qui a été
ressuscité tout comme bran étant la
corneille à trois yeux il est la figure
principale de tout ce qui est mystique
magique
étrange dans game of thrones celui visé
par le roi de la nuit car le gardien de
l'histoire de l'humanité et donc dans
cette direction nous avons deux éléments
assez troublant le premier est le
comportement du roi de la nuit à l'égard
de john snow
nous n'avons par exemple jamais su
pourquoi le nat king agi différemment
quand john snow est en face de lui lors
de la bataille opposant les marcheurs
blanc au peuple libre à la fin les deux
personnages se regarde longuement avant
que le roi de la nuit une phase une
démonstration de ses pouvoirs lors du
sauvetage de john et du groupe par
daenerys le roi de la nuit ne tue pas
drogon qui est sagement posées au sol en
train d'attendre et non il choisit de
tuer vise à riom en plein vol lé laisse
plus ou moins s'en aller alors qu'il
aurait été plus logique d'abattre la
cible immobile lors de la bataille de la
longue nuit où john cherchent activement
la confrontation avec le lightning
ce dernier préfère réanimer les morts
pour occuper john snow au lieu de s'en
charger lui même alors que face à t on
bat
s'écoutait de balayer t on enfin plus
quoi vous constatez maistre je constate
bref pourquoi bien évidemment les choix
narratif est de mise en scène font que
john doit survivre le propulser en tant
que personnage principal ces choix reste
tout de même troublant que signifie
cette liaison entre john et le roi de la
nuit
est ce que ce dernier ne serait pas
important pour les marcheurs blanc dans
un autre délire qui reste perturbant
concernant les marcheurs blanc nous
avons le cas de la scène de john
souhaitant expliqué et montré
l'existence de telles ennemis à daenerys
et même si les gravures présente dans la
caverne reste quelque chose d'ancien et
de tribal le roi de la nuit représente
et reste très différent de celui que
nous avons eues à l'écran nombreuses ont
été les théories sur le net
approuvant l'idée qu'il n'y a pas eu un
seul roi de la nuit mais et si c'était
le cas
game of thrones possède une sorte de
thématiques de boucles nous avons le cas
avec daenerys accédant au trône
à l'aube d'une certaine folie traduisant
clairement le même destin que son père
le retour de john snow a la garde de
nuit comme au tout début de la série
thirion de nouveau la main du souverain
ultime ou encore la scène finale de la
série faisant écho à la scène
d'ouverture
bref nous savons qu'il a existé il y à
des milliers d'années des marcheurs
blanc créés par les enfants de la forêt
afin de contrer l'invasion des hommes
sur leurs terres ces derniers ont été
repoussés mais sont revenus des milliers
d'années plus tard et c'est l'histoire
actuelle que nous connaissons ne sachant
pas ce qu'il ya dans les contrées de
l'éternel hiver soit le royaume des
marcheurs blanc est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas une ultime lueur d'un retour des
marcheurs blanc justement dans le
fonctionnement de ces derniers si nous
tuons le roi de la nuit ou un commandant
tous ses subordonnés réveiller tomberont
en même temps que lui il faut couper la
tête pour faire tomber le corps
mais s il restait un marcheur blanc
cachés dans les terres du nord où
l'hiver ne s'éteint jamais pour
justement perpétuer un éternel retour de
ces derniers
cela expliquerait en tout cas pourquoi
bran enverrait john au delà du mur en
guise de punition
afin que dans son voyage ils puissent
accéder à ces terres du nord afin
d'éradiquer la menace des marcheurs
blanc définitivement est entré
calculateur est maintenant le nouveau
roi cela expliquerait également le fait
qu'il n'avertisse personnes de cette
potentielle menace déjà pour ne pas
affoler mais pour ne peut être pas non
plus changé le cours de l'histoire prévu
sans oublier la mission inachevée de
john qui aurait enfin son heure de
gloire étant le véritable héros qui
mettra fin aux marcheurs blanc néanmoins
deux par le comportement du roi de la
nuit à l'égard de john l'omniscience de
branne et la disparition de drogo avec
le corps de daenerys vous le verrez dans
la vidéo de heroes mais il existe une
possibilité d'un retour de daenerys
enfin qu'elle revienne d'entre les morts
pour être plus précis et si c'était le
cas elle serait une grande menace pour
west & ross elle serait en quête de
vengeance
possédant un dragon le meilleur de ses
trois enfants rappelant le sa puissance
serait juste phénoménal bran soupçonnant
cette menace envers est donc john au
nord dans l'optique de devenir le
nouveau roi de la nuit
la seule entité pouvant vaincre le
retour de deyris on retrouverait bien
évidemment tout le côté shakespearien
dans ce combat opposant john et daenerys
et cela mettrait fin à la mission de
john qui pourrait reposer en paix enfin
en quelque sorte
mais bon c'est à vous de définir quelle
suite vous plaît le mieux john mettant
définitivement fin aux marcheurs blanc
est donc accomplie enfin sa véritable
mission ou john futur nouveau roi de la
nuit pour avoir la force de terrasser
une daenerys avec son dragon plus en
colère que jamais j'attends vos réponses
en commentaire merci en tout cas d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo j'espère de tout coeur
qu'elle vous aura plu et je trouvais que
c'était le bon moyen de fêter les
dix ans de game of thrones effectivement
cette vidéo fait partie d'une trilogie
c'est à dire que mes deux compères
heroes f et m e thibault ont eux aussi
une vidéo a proposé sur game of thrones
avec de très belles théories et de très
beaux récits je vous conseille fortement
d'aller voir leur travail à eux aussi et
puis voilà n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit pouce bleus à vous abonner à la
chaîne à me suivre sur instagram twitter
et ses terrasses est très important et
puis voilà j'étais ravie de vous avoir
parlé de game of thrones ça fait
longtemps que le 'lion' rares soit avec
vous c'était arcoroc allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]